what is it you've seen people do to turn
up the heat to take things to the next
level so I say two things the first is
just staying consistent on the thing I
don't know how many times it took you to
make a video before your channel started
to take off uh for me it was a lot 5
years to get to 2,000 subscribers or
something like that it's just the only
thing I had going for me was I just kept
going I wasn't very good on camera I
didn't have any strategy I didn't really
know what I was doing I felt insecure
all the time I was introverted and shy
and like not a natural Entertainer but I
just kept going and so a lot of times
the answer is just keep going just stay
consistent just make another one just
make another one and I think if you if
you're always focus on the next one
you're making and not so worried about
oh my last one didn't do as well or
wasn't as good a thumbnail or whatever
like okay just like you sucked it
perfect make the next one keep going
there's always another one you're going
to keep doing that's the only thing that
I had going for me in the early days hey
it's EV car Michael and I watch these
videos every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy a lot of times it really
is just continuing to show up because in
the showing up you will slowly get
better you might be naturally talented
amazing but you will even if you suck
you will get better you will slowly get
better at the skill and opportunities
will come to you uh if you're in the
game but like you don't get
opportunities if you're just sitting
thinking about the game you got to be
there in the game and a lot of times we
feel like we're just striking out and
striking out striking out but it's like
it's another bat and then eventually you
get a hit you know and then you keep
striking out and you another hit and you
slowly get better you can play forever
right I mean it's like you can keep
doing this it's not like in a year
YouTube's going to go away and now
you're not going to be able to make it
so just showing up consistently and for
me it's having a calendar and videos
have to go up so this is something I
talk to creators about all the time is
for us it's a daily calendar for
somebody else it might be a weekly or
monthly calendar but a video has to go
up every
day even now how many years later 15
years later whatever it is I still don't
100% love any video that we release
right like I look at like oh we could we
could tweak that and we could change
that such a huge Point yeah it's like we
could there's always something that we
can tweak and fix and if you give me
infinite time with it I'll keep working
and keep working and keep working and
keep working on it but a video has to go
up today and a video has to go up
tomorrow so we do the best that we have
with what we've got and then tomorrow we
release another video and so nothing
gets in the way of the release schedule
so we haven't missed a video upload in
over a decade I don't know you can go on
the channel I guess see when the live
last time we didn't have a a day of
making videos rule number two is believe
I think uh at the start I was very shy
introverted still am man still an
introvert uh but 11 years later 6,000
videos later here we are and belief is
the core uh but I think so I mean guess
maybe lesson for your audience or a
tidbit is yes is belief in yourself and
your abilities to to to close and to
help and to serve and to do a good job
and um but also I think belief that what
you're selling will actually help the
client yeah like I think that's what
really helps move the needle forward is
you know that this thing you know that
these people are struggling with an
issue and that your product or service
can help them then it becomes your duty
your obligation to to persuade to
influence to help because it's of
service to them it's not just you trying
to get the commission right you got to
hit that number for the end of the month
which is important but but then that
when it's when it's selfishly motiv like
that it can be hard to still have that
belief all the time and it's easy for
the customer to kind of see through it
where if you're actually thinking of
them in their own best interest and you
know that your product or service can
help them solve that problem uh it makes
you way more persuasive and convincing
to actually get those numbers for
yourself rle number three is build
relationships especially for your
business referrals are so critical I
mean I don't have to tell you that but
you know for people watching too
thinking about who could be good
referral Partners if you're if you're
taking Canadians and then taking them to
Europe the the lawyers who are experts
in moving businesses over the
accountants who are experts in Italy or
Greece or wherever you're going to go
and send people to uh those are great
relationships to start to build now yeah
and then that sets you up because they
could help refer clients into you as
well it's like oh okay well we already
have clients who moving here and we're
helping them with the legal we need
somebody to help them figure out their
finances talk to Sir she's the guy so
building those relationships is the
fastest way to start getting that
business off the ground uh now how do
you do that with we're talking YouTube
content or Instagram cont how so I guess
I could call them and say hey uh you
want to do YouTube uh together with and
interview them and say hey what do you
see about people coming over to whatever
Italy and what are the things that's
that's the show so the show because of
all the compliance and because of the
kind of timeline that you're working on
the show is not actually for uh the
consumer the show is having people on
who are
your potential referral Partners it's a
business development show yeah so
lawyers never get asked to do interviews
on
anything yeah so if you go in and say
hey do you want to be a potential
partner for me and maybe refer business
to each other they're getting hit up all
the times with business opportunities
and like you're just another financial
advisor that they're that they have to
kind of SWAT away and decide if they
actually want to do something with you
but if you say hey I'd love to interview
you for my YouTube channel that's going
to talk about how Canadians can either
you know invest if it's the Canadian
Market or how Canadians can move
overseas that's what my channel is all
dedicated towards like really you got a
channel for that sure I I'd happy I'd be
happy to come on and then you spend an
hour with them interviewing them now you
buil it a relationship and now they're
asking hey Serge what do you do like
you're the financial guy huh we might
have some clients for you yeah so it
almost doesn't matter how well that
video does it's the point is to not
reach consumers but to connect with
potential referral Partners so it's
business development for you rule number
four is follow your heart you need to
start with the heart and our brain often
will tell our brain's designed to keep
us small Keep Us Safe Keep Us protected
and it doesn't agree with the things
your heart wants to do like come to
Toronto and do this do this thing with
heaven like yeah but this stupid I all
of the reasons why I lost my voice I
should cancel a flight yeah yeah EXA
work yeah right and that all makes
logical sense and like your brain keeps
you safe where your heart wants to
create something brand new and so you
need both both but the big decisions are
with the heart and the starting point is
with the heart that's where creativity
is born right and then as you get going
you can use your brain to figure out do
I do I keep doing this how do I build
how do I inject the science into it so
top 10 profiles yeah I love that all day
let's get smarter at it dance challenges
one and done right right but it gets
back to the story like it didn't start
with science it didn't start with target
market it didn't start with knowing your
audience it didn't start with an avatar
right it started with I'm going to do a
a toour review I don't know this's this
dinosaur here let me do this Tour review
and whatever sparked the seed after that
whether the video did well or you got a
couple comments or it was just fun to do
or like I could do more of this then you
brought the science in and that's how
you blew up you know a channel to having
a billion views right but it starts with
the seed of creativity that you just
said yes to and followed also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special special free worksheet just for
this video the worksheet will highlight
all the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is model success
I make the content for me cuz I want
Grant in my ear and Steve Jobs in my ear
and all these people who've done amazing
things and when you're around it every
day then all of a sudden like this is no
big deal compared to what all these
other people have done and so it makes
you feel like it's possible and that all
of those successful people that are
profiled on the channel their first
answer is not just okay I guess I guess
we quit it's like no no we'll find
another way or at least let me try to
find another way and so the more you
have that being poured into you from
entrepreneurs from athletes from
musicians the people who have
accomplished then it just makes you
start to shift your perspective and
mindset the people you've had on your
show and and this show this podcast it's
always encouraging people it's always
hopeful it's always giving people
optimism and that they don't have to
stay where they're where they are right
now if they're not happy where they've
accomplished a lot to be here that's why
they listen to Josh but you don't have
to stay there you could be way further
you could be out here and you're
bringing on guest to kind of help make
that path happen and so the more you
feed your mind with it the more you
start to become it and think that way
because chances are the people listening
to the show your audience they're
already the most ambitious people that
they
know like you're the one pouring in
other people you're the one for your
community encouraging other people
saying you should do this going like
you're you're the one from your high
school who's already accomplished the
most
probably and that's great like continue
to pour in other people but who pours
into you and and the more successful you
become the fewer there are who can pour
into you and so it's not it's not to say
don't go off and get mentors and join
groups and connect with people is super
important but you can get a lot from
virtual
mentors so you can learn a lot from guys
like Grant and Steve Jobs and whoever
your heroes are even if you never meet
them and it forces you to become a
better version of you rule number six is
build a morning routine you have to
remind yourself of the things that make
you feel bold confident powerful alive
and then put that into your morning
routine because it's a daily thing you
might have the greatest day of all time
today and feel like you're unstoppable
and you're the king of the world and you
can do anything and then you can wake up
tomorrow and that feeling's
gone yeah it's a daily thing so whatever
the thing is that made you feel bold
powerful confident alive put that into
your morning
you know if listening to Jake is the
thing great Jake's got a bunch of
episodes go listen to one every morning
like start your day with Jake right if
it's my YouTube videos or if it's
somebody else's podcast or reading the
book something whatever the thing is
that gets you feeling amazing this is
one of the biggest things that people
don't recognize about high achievement
people expect uh you know Tony Robins or
Brendan bashard or Evan Carle whoever
wake up and go yes Thursday let's go
Crush today right like that doesn't
happen for anybody yeah not for me not
for Jake not for Tony Robbins not for
Michael Jordan not for
anybody right the difference is
successful people high Achievers have a
have a set of Excellence for themselves
they have a routine that they demand
that Excellence from themselves on a
daily basis so if you wake up and don't
feel motivated welcome to being a human
being Jordan didn't feel motivated
either but he did things every morning
to help him get to that spot that's the
only thing that's missing yeah you have
to figure out what is your routine going
to be to get you feeling bold powerful
confident alive which is why I like
having the the office environment
because I don't even have to do anything
I just have to walk in and that's that
gives me an instant hit already rule
number seven is overcome your fears
whether you're an introvert or not
achieving your big scary dream will come
on the other side of all of these fears
so for me I I was massively afraid to if
you hit me up 10 years ago I would have
been terrified to come and do this show
um I still get terrified when I'm going
and doing speeches on big
stages for you even before we started
recording you said you were nervous and
scared to do this interview right like
all of and maybe even in messaging me or
making that video you were nervous or
scared to do it all of the great things
that you want out of life are on the
other side of of your fears yeah and if
you tap into the fact that I'm not even
doing this for me I'm doing this to
serve I'm doing this to help like you're
doing this sure it helps your show but
it's to reach more people it's a spread
a message is you want to help other
people uh anytime I tap into service it
it reduces the fear it takes away that
fear from me and um I remind myself stop
being selfish like you're here to try to
help people so go off and try to do that
rule number eight is learn to monetize
the book without marketing is not going
to generate more business for you okay
so I would love to see you start making
more money and then you can afford to
hire whoever you need to to do whatever
else you need to right so people tend to
default to more like okay oh I need to
write a blog or I need to write a book
or I need to like just create more but
creating more doesn't mean that you're G
to get more clients and get paid more so
if you're a coach having a book does it
add some credibility uh maybe you know
like these days it doesn't really matter
that much if you have a book or not if
it's with a publisher maybe if it's in a
bookstore maybe but are you still buying
books and bookstores you know I don't
know it's like it's not what it used to
be the reason I write a book is because
you want to birth it into the world you
got a big message and for my books like
this just this is better in a book than
it is in a series of videos okay but I
didn't need this book to like
immediately generate business for
me if I was you I would focus on how do
I grow my coaching business
you might have big Ambitions and huge
things you want to do and maybe start
your own publishing company I don't know
you got lots of things that you want to
work on uh so what's the fastest path to
start making some money inside of your
big mission and if you sell coaching the
fastest bath is coaching so what's going
to help you generate coaching clients
your two Best Bets are are coaching
content so like a book isn't coaching
content a book is you being a thought
leader again right so coaching content
content ideally videos where you're
showing right um and any potential
Partnerships like who are they uh who
are people going to when they need a
reset so for example you mentioned
divorce cool go talk to the top 50
divorce attorneys in
Calgary and say here's what I do rule
number nine is be more confident
whoever's more confident wins right so
you need to feel confident before you
pick up the phone and that starts with
you know morning routine rituals but
also the environment that you're in the
clothes that you wear all of it really
matters your confidence so I want to
create an environment of belief whenever
I walk into my office so to you know
what Jake's talking about I've got five
canvases up on my wall the first one you
can't actually see on this angle it's
it's a Steve Jobs picture kind of
staring me down yeah then we got AP
janini who's my favorite entrepreneur of
all time then my parents uh this is me
and my I'm about eight years old here my
parents and then Howard Schultz and then
Kanye West Kanye West yeah I'm in
Calabasas that's
awesome and this is uh you know these
people are staring me down every time I
come to my office and the great thing
about setting up your environment is you
only have to do it once like I set this
up with intention once and then I show
up every day and I got these people
staring me down giving me belief you
know every day and so it's a super
powerful hack to think what makes you
have that confidence have that
self-belief and then whether it's your
computer background your cell phone
background the the art on your walls how
you dress and show up even if you're
working from home will make an impact on
your mental and when your mental is
strong that converts super easy to uh
your customers wanted to buy from you
and feeling like you're speaking the
truth and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
pray for wisdom stop getting pulled in a
thousand different directions that other
people want you to do because you know
what feels true to you so that has to
come from a real place uh I don't think
you can just pick one and say that's
what I'm going to be it has to come from
inside uh I would encourage I would
encourage more prayer Pray I think I
think um people often pray
for help like please help me with this
please take away this problem from me as
opposed to praying for wisdom yeah pray
for wisdom pray for guidance pray for
help and figuring out what your core
value is yeah right pray properly right
don't pray to win the lottery pray for
guidance on how to figure out your most
important core value and I think if you
open yourself up to that and create that
channel um you're much more likely to be
able to find it I think people should
pray for wisdom
more how you can model success this is
what saved my business when I wanted to
quit at my company my first software
company and then I realized that you
know what I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before like somebody
has figured this
out if I just learn from that person I
can apply those strategies to my
business and so I modeled Bill Gates who
started Microsoft and I've never met
Bill Gates but he saved my company and I
looked at the strategies of how did he
start Microsoft not how does Microsoft
grow now who cares it's a huge company
but like start how did he start zero to
one that's what I wanted to do and I
modeled him and I applied that to my
business and started to grow and so
whatever dreams whatever goals whatever
business you have somebody's already
figured it out may not be exactly what
you want to do and that's good because
you're different you're an entrepreneur
you're GNA put your own twist on it but
people have already figured it out and
so understanding what they did and
trying to break down their success could
be really helpful so that if you're
hustling and grinding you're spending
your time on the right things that will
help you as opposed to the things that
aren leading to
success so so when you say model after
them you you mean like you don't
necessarily have to meet this person you
can just read their books or watch their
interviews is that how you learned from
from Bill Gates for example yeah so
there's two kinds of mentors is there's
the regular mentors that people think
about where you go for coffee and
they're you know they're local you can
go meet them and they break down your
business uh and I never had that right
like my parents taught me so much about
life and being a human being but never
about business and nobody in my family
was an entrepreneur and so I had nobody
to go and have coffee with I went to my
banker and said hey can you help me with
my business like well do you need a loan
he like no I don't know do I need a loan
I don't know he's like yeah you're not
really in the right place like I didn't
know anybody and so I Look To What I
Call aspirational mentors these the
people who you aspire to be like or
aspire to learn from and some people may
have already passed on and you'll never
meet them like I have Steve Jobs up on
my wall I'm never going to meet him
obviously um and a lot of people behind
me uh some I may meet one day or some
have passed on uh and so I would look at
two kinds of what I call aspirational
mentors the first are in your industry
whatever you want to do somebody has
done it you want to be a successful
YouTuber there's lots of people who've
done it Go and model them see what they
did the more uh successful they are the
more information there is on them
whether it's interviews or books or
magazine articles like their story is
somewhere and again look to how they got
started as opposed to what they're doing
now because it's a different scale and
then the second kind are just the people
who you look up to you know if if I love
Oprah free I could learn something from
her even if I don't want to have my own
talk show you know if you love Michael
Jordan you could learn from him even if
you never want to be a basketball player
like the way that he works and his
hustle and effort and he's in the gym
you can apply that to your life and to
your business even if you never go on to
try to become an NBA player so those two
things the people who have done what you
want to do maybe you hate them but you
can still learn from their success right
and just do it your way and then the
people who you just really look up to
and really admire and say one day I want
to have that kind of impact again
understanding how they got started and
modeling their success to help you get
your breakthrough the first person I
hired was not in this YouTube business
but but way back in my first company and
it was for one hour a day and I hired
him to do one hour of work a day because
it freed up about an hour and a half of
my time per day and I think honestly as
soon as you can you want to get somebody
to help out it does a couple things one
it it it really helps to not be doing
this alone like it really sucks to do
everything all by yourself just the
emotional I mean you guys have each
other which is
great like join a group join a community
don't be alone because it's really
really really hard to be an entrepreneur
and do it all on your own when all of
those insecurities and fears and doubts
and like I'm not good enough and I was
so dumb for starting this and what was I
thinking and right uh so it's it's nice
to have somebody who's doing this with
you as opposed to you doing it all by
yourself plus it's just smart in that
you don't have to do all the work that
you can delicate some of the tasks away
to focus on whatever is you know more
inside of your passion and what you love
and what you can you know charge more
for as well to build your company why is
it necessary that's one word for
Branding your business so I think it
comes in two forms I think it starts
with you
I think it gives you the clear
perspective on what your brand is all
about I think a lot of times when people
coming up with a brand they don't you
know they're they're picking something
because it looks nice or it sounds good
but it's not coming from a really deep
place of meaning and the brand needs to
mean something first to you like you
need to be proud of everything that
you're creating and it has to have a has
to have a heartbeat everything you make
has to have a heartbeat whether that's a
creating content or or creating the
service like you do coaching you do
Consulting that has to you have to help
people thrive in in those sessions or
you're not going to be you know happy
about that um and so it it gives you a
frame of reference for yourself first
that then that flows through everything
flows into your entire business how you
operate your company uh you know you
want to bring on people to your team who
believe in similar things as you do if
you're hiring a video editor you know my
video editor wanted to tattoo believe on
her arm before she even met
me she she you know she believes in the
same thing and so you want to bring
people on to have the skill set but also
believe the same thing that you believe
and if you don't know what you believe
then you'll attract anybody but if
you're really specific on what you
believe then it's easy to bring people
in who are on the same Mission that's an
internal brand most people look at the
external which we can get to but like
that's the internal brand you need the
internal Compass because if the external
is one thing in the internal of
something else you're not going to be
happy you're going to feel like a fake
you're going to feel like you're always
having to live up to something that
you're not the external then is what
people perceive it as what when people
see your your content when people see
your product or service your your
branding your your Instagram and YouTube
and all of that what do they think what
do they feel if it's too complicated you
know they won't be able to share it
people people could love your stuff but
if they can't articulate it clearly to
their friends and their colleagues
they're not going to share it I think of
uh corporations that have their 13 core
values that no nobody actually knows
nobody shares it because it's too
complicated like if you need me to
remember five things about you to share
it I'm not going to it's just even if I
love you like I'd have to love you
insanely a lot to remember those five
things but if it's if it's one thing and
people know me for belief they want more
Bel in their life it's you should talk
to Evan you should go watch his YouTube
channel you should subscribe to him you
should check out what he's doing it's
just easy to remember because people
have busy lives it's not that they don't
want to talk about you you're just
making it too complicated you're
introducing too much friction to them
share with us some of your tips for
creating super fans yeah I think it
starts with figuring out what is your
message what do you stand for what's
what's the one word that defines you
it's it's what I talk about my first
book but what why should I follow
you like for me I'm about believe so if
you want a shot in the arm of believe
you want to believe in yourself more
you're going to enjoy everything that I
put out you're going to enjoy this
interview you're going to enjoy my
YouTube videos you're going to enjoy my
my upand cominging IG account you're
going to enjoy all that stuff if you
don't like believe you're not going to
like me you're not you're going to tune
out you've already shut off this podcast
you know you don't you're not gonna like
what I have to say and so it's figuring
out what is your message what is so
important and different about you like
why are you doing the thing that you're
doing and then people who like that
message will follow
along most people don't have a message
that they really believe in most people
are just trying to be like somebody
else and that's hard to get like why am
I going to be your Super Fan I'm going
to be that person's Super Fan you're
trying to just be like Logan I'm gonna
follow Logan why am I GNA follow you
what's so different and so it's figuring
out what that thing is that's different
about you what your message is that's
super clear and so that I think whenever
I need an injection of like if you're Mr
inspiration whenever I need inspiration
or whenever I need energy like I'm going
to come you to you I'm going to listen
to your podcast otherwise what's the
reason if I can't if I can't tell
somebody why they need to listen to your
podcast or buy your book or check out
your channel then you're sunk like you
need people talking about you and the
message that you have um now not every
message is a positive one you know some
people make their name off of tabloids
and making fun of people and that's
that's that's escapism so it's either
like people want to either escape the
life that they hate or they want to go
and build a better life for themselves
so you're either playing on the comedy
or on the making fun of somebody else
it's all escaping the life that you
don't have to think about your life you
don't have to think about growth you
just want to shut off your brain and be
entertained or you want to solve the
problems and you want to build a better
life and so that's where you get the
inspiration and the motivation and
practical uh content so just figuring
out where you lie on that path and then
being consistent about it that's why the
journey is important too like if you're
saying hey I love I'm about inspiration
I want to inspire people and everything
I do I want to be an inspiration so I
have my clothing line and I have my
books I have my foundation and now I'm
starting my podcast if you want to be
inspired listen to my podcast every week
and then even when you're booking guests
right you're booking guests who are
going to inspire people right so like
once you get that identity down then it
makes every decision a lot easier and
you give super fans you give fans a
reason to subscribe and then become
super fans humans are built to serve
because if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not
serving and that's that's hardwired into
US serving others helping others hits
the same part of your brain as having
food and having sex so it's it's
literally hardwired into you that you
want to you feel good by serving other
people so if you're not happy right now
you mentioned the word depression if
you're depressed and you're not happy
you're not serving either the world
maybe you have a big mission or big
Vision or the 25 closest people to you
you don't have to have some giant
Mission but you have to feel like you're
serving the people who are closest to
you either one if you're not happy it's
because you're not serving and so the
good news is you can always always
figure out a way to serve exactly
exactly and you can serve on a on a you
know really deep level which is what the
book gets into of how to figure out how
to how to serve exactly but even just
doing an act of kindness even just doing
one nice thing for somebody else will
will make you feel better ultimately
what I want people to do is if you woke
up and you felt like today
mattered like you woke up this morning
and you felt like today mattered you're
going to make something today that
matters you're going to you're going to
create something today whether that's a
song or a video or artwork like you're
creating when you're creating something
that has the potential to impact
somebody else's life if you did that
every day you're you're on a path to
happiness perfectionism is really just
fear you know you're just afraid right
so I try I mean of course I'm still
afraid of many things but if I can catch
it I try not to be or do the thing that
makes me scared but to the Kill Your
Darlings um yeah one of my greatest
fears earlier on uh in my career was
being an aging rock star and so one of
the things that for some reason really
bothered me was you look at these rock
stars who were big in like the 70s or
80s or 90s or whatever and they still go
on tour and like wow they're still on
tour like it's amazing that they're
still on tour but they're still singing
the songs they were singing like decades
ago yes you know like where is the new
stuff like have you had nothing new to
say in 30 years since you of the thing
right and right anytime you're anytime
you're uh judgmental of somebody else
it's self-reflection it's like it's your
own your worried about yourself not
about like Aerosmith or whatever doesn't
care about me or my opinion and I don't
really hate on Aeros Smith so it's like
if you are criticizing somebody else
it's like well look inside because you
have that same thing that you're
criticizing and I realized it was my
fear that I I don't want to be that like
I don't want to be Evan uh you know 30
years later still making videos yay but
like telling the war stories of back in
2023 when you know on with Sean talking
about Tom Brady uh I want to make new
stuff right I want to make new stuff and
I think I've I've overcome that one um I
only bring up the past when people ask
me questions about um about the past uh
but that was yeah that was a big thing
that was a big fear of mine early on
getting started it's like I didn't want
to just hold on to my darlings and sing
the same songs over and over and over
again I think one of the biggest
mistakes I made early on when I when I
had any money was I just tried to invest
it and put into the stock market and I
remember like I had 2,000 bucks like
okay I'm going to put in the stock
market and it's going to grow I like oh
it's like taking so long to grow it's
only 2,000 where Jeremy actually made a
much smarter call like I think at the
beginning you invest in your skills and
you invest in your network because that
$2,500 investment that Jeremy made now
has a mid6 or high six fig business
every year because it came to that event
but if you just put it into the stock
market sure would grow but I think at
the beginning you need to invest in
yourself to get the skills that you need
to be able to then create the network
and create value for other people yeah
and and when entrepreneurs any
entrepreneur here watching you're
thinking about starting your business
the easiest way to start making money is
to provide a high value business or
service to people who have money to pay
you and so getting into YouTube
Consulting is great because there's not
a ton of people into it yeah right it
hasn't been around for 40 years if
you're going to get into tax accounting
that's a great business to be in too but
you have to have years of experience to
know what you're doing right I did um I
did an interview with Tom on his channel
like that guy's an expert he's a genius
he's a genius so if you're going to go
and compete with Tom it's going to take
you so many years to even catch up to a
base level of knowledge but in YouTube
Consulting it's easier because there is
nobody really who been doing this for 40
years right or you're a chat GPT
consultant and you're helping use AI for
people in the C who is the expert on
that like there's nobody because it's
still so brand new so this is the area
where it's super high value for clients
but there aren't a lot of experts at it
so for you to spend six months becoming
great at it you could be now in the top
1% of all people who know how to use
that thing and then start charging for
your services on top of it the point of
the podcast is to help people be unstuck
if it's in relationships if it's in
business if it's in the idea that
they've always had that they want to do
something they want to achieve it's to
unlock that potential cool so you're in
a fortunate position in that you you're
starting it from scratch but you're not
you're not starting from scratch right
you you have you have some contacts in
the industry you know some people you
you can pull sweaters is a analogy an
old Mentor used to give me uh okay where
like you're pulling sweaters to get to
the head of the line sure where you know
enough people that you can get to people
and you can get to bigger and bigger and
bigger people right so you know there's
people who've used your service you've
gone to events you have connections even
you know after this interview goes up
you can see who follows me an easy hack
is like for current guests see who who
follows them on Instagram and then reach
out to them oh so after this interview
goes live see who follows me on
Instagram and then you can reach out to
them and say hey I had EV Kel on my show
I'd love to have you on too wow my name
mean nothing to many people but it means
something to a few people it allows you
to do you know Outreach okay but so you
can you can work your way up and you can
get you can get guests on your show at a
faster clip than most people who are
just tur off a podcast cool right to
what end like how can I bring you value
how can other people come on and bring
Justin value audience value because
that's I guess the work of the uh that's
the brand like what what are we trying
to create here so Unlimited potential
okay awesome I love it I mean I'm all
believe so great I love it is it the
guest is it the format is it people
coming on and coaching you is it like
what are we going to do different on
this podcast compared to all the other
podcasts out there that you know have
the same purpose as you you don't have
to have it all figured out either you
know on this on this call right now but
that becomes the uh the ongoing fact why
would somebody subscribe to the channel
why would they watch what you're doing
you can get guests which is again you
you're not straight from scratch but if
I'm coming on your show how does this
become a different interview or show
than the other ones that that other
people are on that I've gone on other
people's channels and had you know
similar conversations I mean I talk
about Bel and potential all the time so
how does it become different is it about
my potential story is it about your
potential story is it about diving into
a specific like and it all comes from
your heart like what do you actually
want to create the ability to
both recruit team and recruit
clients based not just off the
performance but the story so in your
willingness to share what you've been
through and the mission that you're on I
think it actually attracts the right
people to you both clients and team
which then that can parlay into
something much bigger if you look at you
know Ed milette came from the financial
World Patrick bavid came from the
financial world now doing things outside
the financial World in a big follow them
daily yeah that's their background and
still you know kind heavy ties to the
business but you they don't talk much
about it you don't hear Ed and Patrick
talking about that business too much a
little bit but if you were to see their
show you wouldn't think oh this is the
yeah insurance guy right right but it
becomes a a vehicle to get to the next
step you know if you took the same
courage that you talk about Ali and
Sanders in and bring that to your
business and your content and your
messaging like upfront it's not just
that you're a winner and you can help
them get the deal it's also the story
behind it why would I pick you over
somebody else you have the track record
but other people have the track record
you know is your track that much better
than somebody else's you
know maybe compared to Startup for sure
but there's other people who have more
experience than you do but they don't
have your
story and that combination is where you
start to bring on the right people I
think it's a really hard road to become
an entrepreneur how did you find your
Mentor because that's that's really hard
for a lot of people yeah the trick is
when you when you find somebody who you
like who you think they're ahead of you
and you think they might have something
to contribute like just you have to find
a way to get closer to them so I'll give
you two stories the first with me and
Steve uh I met Steve through one of his
clients so one of his clients was in
Toronto same city as me and we met at a
coffee shop and he had this idea for the
to pitch on a YouTube video and uh he
said that his agent came up with this
idea he like agent like what do you mean
agent how do you have an agent you're
like a business guy or like a YouTuber
how do you have an agent because I
thought agents were only for sports
stars or musicians like how do you like
yeah I have an agent he represents like
thought leaders like ah okay can I can I
meet him and uh so he introduced me to
Steve I hopped on the call Steve made me
feel very uncomfortable you know in all
the in all the right ways um and and
that led to me wanting to do more with
him even though I didn't fit the typical
mold mold so it's it's following the
Curiosity right if I never I met I met
this guy in Toronto his name was Shawn
and if I never asked Shawn about the
agent I wouldn't have had that
conversation um fast forward a couple
years ago there was a guy Jeremy who
came to one of my events and he's paid
like 2500 bucks or something to come to
this event he's 18 19 years old he is
working as a grocery store clerk okay
like hates his life doesn't want to work
grocery store doesn't know what he
really wants to do likes my energy saw
my YouTube videos come to the event
3-day event at the end of the event he
messages me says hey Evan I just want to
like how do I spend more time with you I
don't have any skills yet but I'll I'll
walk your dog I'll I'll clean your car
I'll mow your lawn like I just want to
spend more time with you and I messaged
him back said that's super amazing
Jeremy but I don't like I don't need
somebody to walk my dog or clean my car
but um but thank you um a couple months
later I was driving on my tour I'm
driving through this desert in Texas and
I think of Jeremy and I thought huh
maybe I could teach Jeremy YouTube like
I wonder people keep asking me about
YouTube and they want me to do work on
their Channel and I don't I don't want
to do that as a business but maybe I
could teach Jeremy how to do it and so
we got Jeremy on the phone that moment
oh uh he he took a little break from his
grocery store you know job and said
Jeremy I want to teach you YouTube we'll
start a business together and I'm away
for the next two months on the road so I
need you to watch all of these videos
and learn everything you can about
YouTube and when I come back if you've
done that I'll help you build a YouTube
Consulting business wow um and we did
and now he's got uh a high six fig
YouTube business uh Consulting he he
made six figures in the first six months
or so having his business um and that's
from being a grocery store clerk right
but if he didn't do that Outreach to me
I wouldn't have taken a shot on him
either it's just the the heart and the
energy and the care and he's just I'll
wash your car and I'll clean you know
hang out with your dog I just love the
energy and even though nothing came up
in the moment he was in the back of my
mind to say okay maybe I should do
something with Jeremy and so it's it's
trying to be in a room where you get to
talk to them but then it's it's almost a
uncomfortable like next ask and show
your hunger and your commitment level
and then the key thing is when you get
that is you ask one question to the
mentor cuz successful people actually
love mentoring but they also hate
wasting time like time is the most
valuable asset and they love mentoring
but they hate wasting time and a lot of
mentees waste time yeah because they
don't do the work so the best thing you
can do if you want if you're trying to
get into a mentorship relationship you
ask one question like what's the one
question you've got to ask Robert kosaki
one
ask then ask another what people do
they'll come and say what about this and
what about that it's like no no no like
do the work on the first question that
he gave you an answer for yeah and then
go home and actually do the work and if
you get a result then you can come back
and ask the second question hey I asked
you this I did this now my I've got five
Apartments man thank you from your
advice now I'm struggling with this he's
much more likely to give you a second
answer because of the work you did on
the first one yeah or if the advice
didn't work make sure that you tried it
a hundred times right it wasn't just you
tried you made one phone call and it
didn't work and so the the advice sucked
right because if you tried it a 100
times and you showed the effort then
he's willing to answer a second question
what is the entrepreneurial mindset how
do they think wow I think it I think it
roots from a a dissatisfaction with the
world around us uh entrepreneurs are The
Crazy Ones who see a better future are
upset about something and then we want
to make make a change where I think
anybody can pick out something that they
don't like in their world but the
entrepreneurs are the solution providers
they're the ones who want to find a way
to solve it and to make the world a
better place somehow and I think most of
our Global problems could be solved by
entrepreneurs if they were given the
opportunity a feeling that I have the
power to be able to make a change where
I think a lot of people who might be
inside a a corporation or an
organization they see a problem with how
their organization is run if you're you
know you work at a library you see tons
of problems with the library but then
you feel oh I can't do this because I
don't have the power it's not my
position it's not my job title where the
entrepreneurial mindset is I'm going to
find a way to make a difference I'm
going to find a way to make a change if
I don't like something at this Library
I'm going to step up and do something
even though it's not my position uh and
so I think adopting that mindset and
just that ability to feel like I'm
empowering myself I don't need
permission from somebody else to say
what I can and cannot do I'm going to do
something to try to make a positive
impact and uh one for the individuals in
the organization to feel like they can
go and take that leap and then two for
the leaders of those organizations to
empower their team to take risk and do
something different and not say you can
only do what's inside this box I think
everybody can can lean in and learn
whatever they want to learn um I had the
Good Fortune of having some great
parents on the they're on the wall
behind me here I'm eight or nine years
old and those are my parents there and
they would always tell me hey you
everything with TR car M like you do
anything you believe that you can and so
they helped instill that in me um I
think the whole you know the Gary V's
point about are you born with it well
what were you doing at 7 years old like
were you doing lemonade stains and
garage sales and taking some initiative
um but if you weren't don't feel like oh
my gosh now I can't be an entrepreneur
it's it's so much easier now than ever
to start your own business or to lean in
on the thing for sure like I believe
everybody's got Michael Jordan level
genius at something like you're the
greatest in the world at something and
you just don't believe that you are and
you don't believe in your dreams enough
to go chase them down but you can
whether it's being an entrepreneur and
believing in your business whether it's
believing in your health Journey that is
possible whether it's you know climbing
Mount kilero or losing 100 pounds or
like whatever the thing is that you'd
love to do it's it's possible people
like you have done it and that's where a
lot of people get stuck is like well
it's possible like somebody else has
done it but I can't do it because I'm
whatever and my story early with the
YouTube stuff was um I'm an introvert
I'm shy so I'm I'm not going to make it
you know but I'll keep making content
because I'm serving but I'm I'm never
going to be the big name because I'm too
introverted and tooo shy and I still am
by the way it just doesn't come out when
I'm doing shows like this um but you can
you know you can whatever whatever that
story is in your head it's totally
fixable and other people you know like
you have done it it and it just comes
down to starting to change what you put
into your head I think that's the
biggest thing of all it's why I make so
much content
because if somebody felt like their
health Journey was impossible you know
it's like you know J you don't
understand was impossible you know it's
like you know J you don't understand
I've been like this and my family has
been like this and it's just not
possible and I've tried a million things
and just nothing works and it's it's
never going to happen Jay just that's
that's who I am right if they spent a
month with you you know because you're
more confident in their ability to get
healthy than they are and their
inability to get
healthy and same thing with me if
somebody's hanging out with me for an
extented period of time if we were
hanging out together uh I'm going to get
a lot healthier
probably and you're going to be making
more YouTube videos man we're going to
get you on there and and crushing it
because whoever is more confident wins
and so the problem is we're surrounded
by people who don't believe in our
dreams who tell us that it's not
possible and we're also feeding our mind
with things that keep us stuck where we
are and if you want to change something
it's totally possible but it starts with
actually changing um that environment so
that you have a you have the crutch like
to get going to get you out of the
Starting Gate you have to do the work
that you don't see as work uh Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture that you
can endure it's like for a lot of people
what you're doing staying up to 3 in the
morning just to do a YouTube Interview
people are like dude that's crazy that's
torture I would never do that right for
people jumping into my schedule like to
make three YouTube videos every day they
would think that that's torture for me
it's fun I enjoy the process if you only
have a goal and you don't like the
process you'll never hit that goal yeah
you have to enjoy the actual work like
if you're gonna interview people you
have to enjoy interviewing people if you
don't you're never gonna have a good
interview Channel like other guys who
love that will crush you and so if
you're just starting out I think people
easily get tricked into looking at what
are the hottest Industries for this year
and what's the next big opportunity
let's go all in on bitcoin meanwhile you
know nothing about Bitcoin yeah you know
and then that's that's the fastest way
to lose your money so you have to do the
thing that you love it's so easy to
complain and and it's a default mode
it's nice to think that it's the
president's fault that you're not
successful or your mom's fault or the
school system's fault or you don't have
enough money or whatever it's nice to
think that that's the reason and what
that does is by blaming somebody else it
puts you in an unresourceful state it
means it's not your fault so you don't
have to fix it it's your mom's fault M
it's the president's fault right it's
their fault so I'm GNA complain and be
angry about it but I don't have to do
anything about it because it's not my
fault so it's when you say okay this is
actually my responsibility it may not be
your fault but it's your responsibility
to fix it that I can get I can get out
of this what that does at the start is
well that sucks you know it's because
it's so nice to be able to blame
somebody now they're SU sucks that it's
on me to go off and fix it but then it's
also the ultimate power in that you can
change your circumstances you can change
your situation you can make it better
just by saying it's on me to fix it like
there's no Cavalry coming by by kicking
the president out of office it doesn't
change your situation you know so so
stop waiting for something else to
happen like you are in charge uh and so
for for any spot in life like you were
you are where you are because of you and
I have a test that I call the mirror
test where you walk in the mirror go
into the bath or wherever you have a
mirror and ask yourself why am I not
more
successful why have I not hit my goals
and whatever the first thing that comes
back when you look in the mirror those
are the excuses that you need to bust
through right because something's going
to come up that's an excuse It's a story
you're holding on to I don't have the
right parents or I don't go to the right
school or I don't know how to be
charismatic or whatever it's some it's
always some excuse um and that's the one
that you need to work on immediately to
fix so you can go build that better life
for yourself failure is a really
interesting topic and it's something
that that we uh we see as a bad thing
for some reason where failure is really
feedback failure is a learning
experience failure is only really fail
if you don't take anything and learn
from it and again you don't have to jump
in and go all in and be the risky
entrepreneur uh I think everybody fails
in their path to success everybody fails
not just entrepreneurs anybody in any
and anytime you're trying to learn
something you will fail at the start you
will suck at the start right you want to
learn French you're going to fail along
the way to learning French right you
want to get up on a snowboard you're not
going to Ace it the first time down
you're going to fall fall fall fall fall
and eventually you make it up right and
so the notion that you would start a
business or start any project and have
instant success is crazy and people try
something out for the first time when
they're not successful at it and a lot
of them will then say yeah I'm not an
entrepr oh that's not for me I can't do
this and they go back to their life that
they hate where that's just a learning
experience right just the key I think is
to make small failures like fail small
fail small don't go go crazy and bet the
house and your mortgage and put your
entire family at risk exactly that's
that's where it gets dangerous but in
terms of teaching small failures I think
I think we kind of already do through um
through our upbringing in our school
system and a lot of the things that we
do but but I think just uh showcasing
that failure is not this really negative
thing that we want to run away from
because if you have no failures it means
you're playing life so safe that you've
never taken any any risk at anything any
shot at anything right you you have a
dream to accomplish something you're
going to fail a lot to get there and I
just see failure as feedback not as
something that is a negative thing I
don't enjoy being the center of
attention it doesn't it doesn't um it
doesn't do anything for me but where it
started to shift was well I still want
to serve you know like I still want to
feel like what I do matters to people
and that I wake up and I'm having a
meaningful impact and so whereas I've
had to learn to harness
the power of the introvert and and
figure this stuff out as I go but also
learn from other introverts and that
okay so I don't like networking meetings
I hate small talk I don't talk to the
guy next to me on the airplane I all of
that stuff but but I love meaningful
conversations and I can get like I see
Patty an in my calendar like this is
gonna be amazing let's go and so how how
do how do you show up with that energy
well I don't know I'm not I think
introverts still want to serve
introverts still want to have meaningful
connections introverts still want to
feel like what they do matters and the
more I can tap into that than than my
energy and enthusiasm that is in
everybody um comes out so it's just it
was but that's that was years of I wish
I knew you 10 years ago like things
would have been so much better I expect
to fail all the
time I expect everything I do especially
at the beginning to not work right if
I'm launching something new I just don't
expect it to do well at the beginning
because it's because creativity is messy
and people put this label Perfection on
it I want it to be perfect but you don't
even know how to make it yet so just get
it out there I value the momentum more
than the
Perfection and so I don't if you're
looking to believe that it's going to
work out that's a big picture macro
concept that any video that I make on my
YouTube channel may not
work and if it's a brand new thing I
expected not to work but it's the belief
that if I keep going it will eventually
work right that I'll figure it out that
I'll adjust that I'll learn something
and I'll prove the next one so I think
people need to give themselves
permission to fail at the beginning for
it not to work out and to not take that
personally doesn't mean that you suck
just because your first song didn't hit
it big just means you learned a little
bit and keep going and if you keep
making new songs and every day you're
practicing and trying to get better
eventually it will work out and I just
fully believe that I can do it that you
can do it that everybody watching and
listening can do it people just quit too
soon and they're trying to be too
perfect until they never get to where
they need to be what is the importance
of video influencers watching maybe
thinking about focusing their branding
and their messaging yeah I think if
you're a human being you have a core
value there's something inside of you
that is the most important value Val in
the world something that you place
higher than money and when you figure
out what that is and then you bring that
not just to your business but to your
life the people you hang out with but in
the context of creating a YouTube
channel the content like how do you
stand out if you are another family
vlogger another gamer another
entrepreneur and there's tons of
competition how do you do it it's based
off of what is the single most important
core value that you want people to feel
cuz I want people to feel an emotion
when they watch my videos when they
watch these interviews I want you to
feel an emot
and not just get content got it so your
one word is believe right it is what's
the story behind that how did you come
over that uh it came from my parents
they always taught me that I was an I
was Evan cast Carmichael I could do
anything that I wanted and it's a
message I still pass on to my son and
they just made me feel like whatever I
wanted to do it was possible and to
believe in myself to do it and it's it's
come through my entire life my favorite
movie is Sea Biscuit it's about this
horse that is too small and a jockey
that's too big and a owner that had no
money they come together it's this
Underdog Story and so anything around
believe just I feel better about now
translated that to a YouTube world when
I had my channel I saw my channel but
like my first video that took off that
did well was this video took me a year
to get to 100,000 views on it and I was
like I was so happy 100,000 views for a
lot of you watching and maybe more than
what you have right now I was so pumped
I made a video around believe which was
my one word and we hit 100,000 views in
a month and that video now has over 2
million views and now believe oozes out
of everything that I create so I'm
trying to give you the content that you
can use to grow your business but I want
you to feel out of every piece of
content that you can go off and do
whatever your main Big Goal is I want
you to feel believe out of everything
that I create I'm writing a new book
about finding your purpose and turn into
a business and then I included the last
chapter on how to make money because I
think a lot of people feel icky or
nasty about trying to well I just love
helping these people so I can't charge
for this I think it actually is selfish
not to charge for it I think it becomes
your your obligation that you have to
charge for it not to everybody I think
you there'll always be a percentage if
it's 10% or 20% of people who who get in
for free because they can't afford it
but if you don't learn how to make money
from your purpose then it will always be
a hobby and you'll always have to do a
full-time job to then support your hobby
where if you actually made it a business
and learned how to make money us doing
it serving people in an ethical you know
life-changing positive way then you can
reach more people you can build a team
you can scale up now instead of as maybe
as a hobby you can hit 10 women a month
W hobby but if you have a business and
now you're you're building a team of
amazing women who all want the same
thing maybe now you're reaching ions of
women wow so I think it I think it's
your responsibility to to turn that into
something that then can create a ripple
effect greater than just a hobby on the
side whoever it is that you look up to
like who's who's done the thing that you
want to do if you love Kanye if you love
Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or Oprah or
whoever it is that you look up to look
at their story look at how they got
started it'll do two things for you one
it'll it'll give you the tactics like
what did this person do to become
successful and two it'll give you the
motivation because chances are the
people who you look up to started off
with a lot less than what you currently
have right now uh one of the people I
love looking up to is Oprah she you know
was sexually abused growing up she
didn't grow up with her parents uh her
grandmother raised her she was so poor
that she her grandmother bought bags of
potatoes and used the potatoes to then
sew it into a dress and Oprah went to
school in potato bags it's like just
imagine showing up in school and a
potato bag as a dress you know it's it's
crazy and so it's hard to imagine that
whatever situation you think is so
terrible in your life right now that
Oprah had it you know way worse than
what you're going through and look at
what she was able to do and so people
have done it so getting out of the
excuses in your head of why re what
resources you feel you don't have or
what circumstances life was thrown
against you people with a lot less of
than a lot more and so model their
success and go after it we know what we
sell perfect let's use social media to
help us sell more of our stuff like the
the big reason why people quit is
because you feel like you're wasting
time making content and it's not Genera
any sales for you and I'm Mission first
purpose first if anybody is familiar
with my content what I do it's like
purpose first and you have to make money
because if you're not making money
you're going to quit on the thing so how
can we make money inside our purpose
instead of having to have some job
that's outside our purpose right so the
next thing to think about if you know
what you're in or what you are looking
to sell right next is who are referral
partners for us so actually KS if you
look at your business like who are the
types of people who refer clients to you
how do you come up with your video ideas
to keep your community
engaged that's a combination of what do
I want to make with what are people
asking for and I think that's at the
success of any any successful business
not just a YouTube channel not just a
podcast or show it's like what do you
love doing with where is their demand if
you take something that you just love
doing but nobody cares you have a
hobby great could be a really fulfilling
hobby but it's just a hobby and if you
take something that everybody wants but
you don't really care about you're never
going to win because you're you're doing
work that you hate and there's somebody
else out there who loves doing that
thing and so don't spend your time doing
work that you hate so it's in that
combination of like what do I love doing
with what do people actually want that
every business can become successful so
for me um we get a lot of feedback from
the audience people leave comments like
hey I'd love to see a video on blank and
maybe I know how to do that and maybe I
really resonate with that or maybe I
don't and and then we don't um or just
starts with me saying I think this could
be a cool idea and then I try to make
that video and put it out there uh and
sometimes they take off and they do well
and we do a lot more and sometimes it
completely flops it's like okay cool
well nobody lik that move on to the next
idea
I think the key though within all of
that is we're not so attached to this
thing having to work a lot of times
people when they're first launching
their YouTube channel their business
their podcast whatever we put so much
pressure on the on the launch being
perfect and then if it doesn't work out
we feel like a failure where for me it's
just okay we're going to try that and
we're going to try this we're going to
try that and and something's going to
work and if that that thing yesterday
didn't work cool I've got 18 more ideas
I'm going to try until I find the thing
that does work so I start out the book
around mediocrity and it gets it gets it
gets pretty angry I think and pretty
pretty pretty aggressive I want to start
the book off strong I think you know
ultimately I think everybody has the
ability to be great I think everybody
has Michael Jordan level Talent or like
whoever your favorite entrepreneur or
person or like somebody who you think is
just amazing at what they do I think
everybody has that I think everybody has
that ability you might not be able to
play basketball better than Michael
Jordan but you can be Michael Jordan of
something yes I agree yes Michael Jordan
is is special but he's not that special
at the same time like everything I've
done on YouTube is special but I'm not
I'm I'm just like everybody else I'm not
that special like you could do what I'm
doing you could do it better than what
I'm doing in your own thing don't don't
don't come after me and do believe in
top 10 I'll I'll Crush you on that but
like you could do your own thing right
like people watching you could do your
own thing and so most people settle for
just a mediocre life it's just okay
you're just paying your bills you're you
know you you may not hate your life
totally but it's it's just okay and and
I want I want to shake people out of
that I want you to feel like you know
you have an ability to be a genius like
you already are a genius and we got to
untap that and the best way that I know
how at to start is through
self-awareness and so I think it begins
with core values it begins with your one
word but even if you think the whole
thing doesn't make sense like just
understanding that you could be the
Michael Jordan of something and and you
should be allergic to mediocrity that
it's not accept cable for you to to not
live the life that you want to go off
and live how could someone like take
their business and evolve it with them
what kind of things could they
do just think about what is it that you
want to create so for example I had a
successful website it was off my name we
had lots of successful people writing
for it um making money off advertising
coming to the site I was getting
restless and so I said I'm going to try
something new I'm going to I want to go
to YouTube I'm going to try that and I
tried a whole bunch of stuff like you
try things you don't know at the
beginning it was going to work out or
not so I tried YouTube as one of many
things and I liked it and so I kept
doing it and then I kept doing it and I
evolved my business a lot of people
don't even know me for my website they
only know me from my YouTube channel
yeah right because we we've blown up
there but if I get bored of YouTube like
the minute that like I like talking to
you this is great Michael's Michael's
doing an interview I love it let's get
on board the minute this feel feel like
work like it's oh man I got to talk I
got to do another interview this sucks I
I need to quit I need to do something
else because you will never win doing
work that you hate okay and so the
minute that this feels like a job I need
to stop and go off and do something else
what is it something else you know like
just ask yourself what what what would I
do what do I want to do what do I want
to work on yeah you may not have the
perfect vision yet for like the final
goal but find some small thing to get
started on something you say that I love
is that you can't out Evan Evan I want
to know what you mean by that yeah I
think a lot of times we we have role
models we have mentors and there's
nothing wrong with it I love I've
learned a lot from the people in my life
and people have profiled on my channel
uh but it it's easy to turn into
impostor syndrome to feel like well I'm
never going to be as good as whoever
like you're here starting this podcast
uh and you might look at Joe Rogan or
Tim Ferris or whoever whoever you think
is the best podcaster interviewer out
there but the goal is never to be Joe
Rogan the goal is to be the best Samuel
possible and that is an evolution and
even at the beginning if you start
asking Joe Rogen questions that's fine
as a as a you know you're tasting and
testing and getting started but we're
always so worried about chasing our
competition where really the goal should
be to be the best us and so nobody can
out Evan Evan nobody can out Samuel
Samuel and so when people
uh will often share videos with me to
say oh look this person copied your
style this person is doing exactly what
you're doing like that's cool like I
don't you're not going to out me me so
if you're just going to be a elfis
impersonator great like keep doing you
but ultimately everybody needs to find
their own path so I think so many times
we're worried about the rearview mirror
and what's happening behind us as
opposed to forging our own path to say
okay how am I going to be unique what do
I love doing that other people don't and
going all in on that thing the more that
you can make choices
that build self-respect and build
character the more you're capable of
making more choices like that people
think of it as some giant thing like
whatever your goals are I talked to a
lot of entrepreneurs so they want to
start their business but whatever your
goals are your personal your health
goals your Fitness your relationship
your business goals whatever they are
it's not just some one thing one giant
goal that you chase it's the daily minor
decisions that you have to make it's
every day you have this choice to am I
going to do the thing I said I was going
to do or am I going to not do it you
know like am I going to let myself down
again here or am I going to do the thing
that makes me proud and it's in in these
minor decisions that we have every day
that ultimately leads to you building
your character so I when you started
your show it's great amazing a lot of
people would love to start a show like
you did a lot of people would love to
have guests on their show as well and
they'd immediately have that insecurity
in their head come to say well who who's
going to listen to me and what am I
going to talk about and which guest is
going to want to come on my show and
they've been on other shows how am I
better how am I different and my show
and they've been on other shows how am I
better how am I different and what that
does is shut down your action to go and
create the show and the more you listen
to that voice the the less action you do
and the more you teach yourself that you
suck do it you're training yourself to
not do it again the next time and not
doing it because this becomes your
identity like I'm the person who has
great ideas but never follows through
and that is something that we have to
start to consciously destroy on the
health Journey well I'm just a fat
person and I can't stick to a diet and I
can't do anything I can't run more than
a mile I can't like and we've created
this identity but all of those things
are fixable but it's not one giant leap
right you don't just get healthy by
going to the gym one day it's the
everyday consistency that you train
yourself for I think the the ultimate
reason resource is your ability to be
resourceful um the line that comes to
mind is from Steve wnc who co-founded
Apple who said stop thinking about all
the things that you don't have and
instead think about what you can do with
what you do have and I think that's uh
an important line for any entrepreneur
it's easy to look at the million reasons
why you're not going to win there's a
million reasons why you will not win and
and you know Gary and I can sit down and
brainstorm a million more reasons why
you're not going to win uh but there's
like eight why you will and so all I do
is focus on those eight and be as
resourceful as possible on those eight
you don't even now if I'm trying to
build my business you know I have 24
people on my team I've had success with
what I'm doing but I don't have a
thousand people on my team and I could
sit and complain around how I don't have
a thousand people or I can say well I
have 24 what can I do with my 24 and
that's always the mindset think about
what you can do with what you do have
and understand that whoever your heroes
are whoever you look up to whoever your
role models are in life whoever's had
massive success chances are they started
with with less than what you already
have right now whether you're looking at
Oprah or Richard Branson or whoever it
is they started with less than what you
already have right now and so if they
could do it you can too the only
difference is your willingness to be
resourceful believing in ourselves is
being true to ourselves we're not
changing who we are to serve others
we're serving others as we are right and
that's critical the authenticity the
genuiness how how did you segue that to
Sala dancing so never learned to dance
growing up I always felt kind of awkward
at a club or whatever dancing and uh in
University I decided okay I'm gonna I
want to learn how to dance and so there
was a there was a ballroom class that I
took with my then girlfriend not Nina um
and we signed up and took the class and
she never really liked it uh we went
couple lessons maybe a semester and then
she didn't want to do it anymore and it
was a kind of class where you you have
to go with a partner and so I didn't
have a partner and I didn't want to ask
another girl to be my partner when I'm
in a Rel it didn't feel right You' can
get in a lot of trouble doing that Evan
Ju Just saying yeah yeah so okay so
that's the end of that whatever fine you
know there's other things to do but then
when we end up breaking up one of the
things I said was well I can go dancing
again like why don't I go learn some
dancing and salsa dancing is the easiest
dance to be able to pick up as a solo
person so what I mean that is when
you're dancing it's part of the culture
to switch Partners all the time so even
if you come as a married couple it would
still be normal to dance with other guys
for you and other women for me which is
part of the cult now some people stay
together but for the most part the
culture is very interchangeable it's
part of the energy I would imagine yes
and borom is very specific it's like you
got your One partner salsa is more of a
street dance and I just fell in love
with it now on paper I'm Too Tall I take
big steps I don't speak Spanish I didn't
learn this growing up uh you know all of
the things that we could say are logical
reasons why you shouldn't do it and I
think a lot of us live in the world of
well I I can't do that and I shouldn't
do that without ever even trying and I
wasn't even very good at the beginning
either because a lot of those reasons
but I just loved it you know there's
something about like this is amazing I
had to I I signed up for two different
schools to go learn because I was a slow
learner at it but just to pick it up and
and I love meeting people I love the
connection I love I love I think also
learning a new skill that you thought
was too difficult also is how you build
belief in yourself to say well I
couldn't I can't do that but then you
see that you can raises your belief
level to do other things so that made me
a better entrepreneur do you feel like
some people are just that entrepreneurs
are
born I know you say that everybody has
enough to serve but you think there's
some people that are just more prone or
um more gifted or more capable when it
comes to um achieving
entrepreneurship so I think I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something okay uh if you
go religious you know everybody's a
child of God you were created you are
beautiful you should be making something
amazing in the world you are not meant
to be living this small life right so if
everybody has Michael Jordan level
Talent at something for some people
that's being an entrepreneur for others
it might be being a teacher in the
school right it could be many things how
do you find it well you need to
explore you need to taste you need to
test you know just like you found my
videos you were searching for motivation
and you found them and then you he like
I like this and then you dop into it a
lot of times you can't think your way
through these things because chances are
the thing that you should be doing is
very different than what is in your
family and in your circle most of the
time the thing that you should be doing
with your life is very different than
what your parents did or what your
brothers or sisters or cousins or
Community or church people there are
doing yeah and so it takes courage to go
off and do it right if if you're if
you're working with women who have a
belief system of well women are supposed
to be this way but then they know that
like I don't want to be that I'm I'm
greater than that I know I'm greater
than that right yeah to have the courage
to chase that dream down I think is
important and that's where I think
people like you are a voice
[Music]
for 10 more amazing rules for me watch
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I think for the first
20 or so years I really lived through
that lens of future regret like whenever
I didn't know how it would turn out and
was afraid of doing something I would
use that model of okay